hey youtubers is Charlie and no you are
not dreaming Stephen Amell totally
leaned in for a felicity kiss in a new
arrow season 3 promo so I'll explain
what was going on with that you may have
seen it on Twitter last night but in
response I'm gonna do my top 5 superhero
couples like from all comics not just
from Marvel and DC there's also some big
casting news to Rila Fukushima is
replacing Deven Aoki as katana in season
3 so I'll explain what happened there
with the switch important stuff first if
you were on Twitter last night you may
have seen the olicity kiss hashtag it
was a little bit mysterious because
arrow has not posted like a new promo
for season 3 in a little while
however there was a super short video of
Oliver almost kissing felicity when you
zoom in you see that he's just leaning
in really close and whispering something
to her he's almost kissing her which was
enough to birth the olicity kiss hashtag
so think of it this way if you rewind to
the season 2 finale with Slade took the
wrong woman moment that's basically what
was going on Oliver just ambiguously
showing affection and communicating
something secretly there's no real
context for the promo scene so do not
take it at face value the show does a
really great job of building the olicity
sexual tension without trampling on the
future they were only good about not
writing themselves into a corner but in
the spirit of the olicity craziness here
are my top 5 superhero couples so this
is from both Marvel and DC but number 5
black panther and storm marvel's royal
couple bringing them together was such a
huge deal for the phantom especially
after the Civil War arc but behind the
scenes it was also a really big thing
for Marvel because it connected the
x-men and The Avengers franchises
basically Marvel's two biggest teams and
because the characters were both born as
Royals in their respective societies it
was kind of like Marvel's royal wedding
they've always had a lot of fun with
epic weddings I think the wedding of
Jean Grey in 1994 was the next biggest
thing in comics after the death of
Superman and Batman tonight Falls saga
Cyclops and Jean Grey were never my
favorite comic book couple though
recently things have not gone so hot for
storm and black panther the x-men vs.
Avengers are was basically the end of
their marriage so you can blame the
Phoenix for that one but on to number
four Superman and Wonder Woman in the
new 52 universe I feel like as
controversial as the new 52 reboot was
for DC's titles getting Superman and
Wonder Woman together was
huge huge deal they'd already done it in
Kingdom Come but that was an alternate
universe story and not really considered
part of the Canon of the main versions
of the characters the new 52 reboot was
basically meant to solve all those
continuity problems so Geoff Johns
basically put everything into a single
continuity so thus Wonder Woman and
Superman became like one of the first
new big things of that you can let me
know whether you love them together or
totally hate the idea but it's like
whenever Marvel rebooted spider-man so
that he wasn't married to Mary Jane
anymore you know Superman was not
married to Lois Lane it is kind of hard
to believe they hadn't gotten these two
big characters together before
essentially they're both alien gods who
are totally undateable
you know below a certain tier of
superhero it's like if you're not
indestructible you will not be able to
be in a sexual relationship with either
one of those characters
I remember whenever I read Kingdom Come
for the first time and saw Wonder Woman
paraded all I could think about was what
are those babies powers gonna be like I
know their powers appear similar but
Wonder Woman has a much more celestial
origin story so let me know what you
think that Superman and Wonder Woman's
baby would be like but on to number 3
arrow and black Canary from the comic
books I know arrow teased it a little
but since they're telling an origin
story there is no way Oliver is gonna
get married in the second season Stephen
Amell would not stand for it it was a
lot of fun in the comics though and the
interesting thing is is that you know as
Oliver has tried to become more of a
hero on arrow in the comics it was
actually kind of his downfall that was
the end of his marriage to Black Canary
it happened after all of our killed
Prometheus which was obviously super
dark but that was only after Prometheus
killed Roy Harper's daughter and maimed
him that was just a string of tragedies
I'd be surprised if any marriage could
survive that that whole arc was a
terrible story for Roy Harper so nobody
let Colton Haynes read it he will just
get so depressed but on to number two
Batman and the Selina Kyle Catwoman if
you ever read the earth-2 comics the
Huntress was the daughter of Batman and
Selina Kyle her name was Helena Wayne
that was an alternate universe though
the version that arrow did was Helena
Bertinelli so Batman and Catwoman never
got married officially in the comics
like they were never official but they
had sex so many times that you would
think they were living together rule
number one of Batman relationships
though is nothing lasts forever even if
you have access to a Lazarus Pit they
did get together in the new 52 comics
but their relation
chip is still described as being
estranged which basically means you
broke up but you still booty call each
other with the bat-signal on occasion
I'll be really interested to see what
kind of relationship the Gotham TV show
gives to Bruce Wayne and Selina Kyle
essentially they're both about 13 years
old so they'll probably just be like
really good friends that help each other
out but my number one comic book ship
gambit and rogue the thing that really
made me fall in love with the two of
them together was the 90s cartoon I
watched that way more than I read the
comics of the 90s one of the fun things
about the two of them was that they were
always this pair of lovable scoundrels
like they weren't royalty like storm and
Black Panther so they seem more like
people that you would want to hang out
with one of the problems with a low
superheroes is that it seems like the
more powerful you get the less
interesting you are to talk to gambit
and rogue were so much fun that you
would just forget about the problems
that apocalypse and Magneto were causing
and mr. sinister lately the comics have
not been so nice to their ship gambit
basically turned traitor
joined apocalypse as one of his four
horsemen and then was working for mr.
sinister they have been teasing a
reconciliation in gambits spin-off comic
but that remains to be seen
rule number one of any comic book couple
nothing lasts forever but rule number
two is that everything comes back around
eventually
so even if people break up they'll
totally get back together at some point
that's always the fans dilemma of
getting what you want as a superhero
nothing is permanent so it means that
you know two characters get together
ultimately they're gonna get broken up
somehow
one minute you're right and hi you have
everything and then something jumps out
and stabs you in the back
a villain returns like Malcolm Merlyn
just to tie it back to arrow you start
to get distracted just because your
girlfriend's face shines so bright you
can't see anything else you don't see
count vertigo sneak into the city and
you don't see the threat of the League
of Assassins and Ra's al Ghul in the
distance I mean even as a fan of the
show that's one of the reasons why
totally don't want Oliver and Felicity
to like completely get together I feel
like it would kill a lot of the tension
and Oliver would be completely
distracted from taking care of the real
problems they will always be a family
though in the sense that team arrow is a
family of people that deeply deeply care
about each other let me know if you
agree though I feel like it's an
unspoken rule that superheroes and even
super villains do not get to have
traditional families they can have
children they just can't have normal
relationships for instance Batman has
Talia and Damian but that totally did
not end well Oliver in the
it says Connor and they have a terrible
relationship so think about it this way
if Oliver and Felicity ever did get
together do you think it would
absolutely kill the show you have to
remember the minute he started having
sex with Black Canary in season two
everything went south there's no wrong
answer but I feel like not knowing how
they're gonna end up is way more
exciting than seeing it happen at the
risk of being super disappointed after
so moving along more current news Rila
Fukushima has replaced devin Aoki as
katana in arrow season 3 it's all
because of scheduling conflicts and
whenever I say that usually what that
means is that actors get signed to a
contract for a specific period of time
that the show expects to film during the
year and the shooting days get moved
around till they overlap with actors
other commitments so either Devin yogi
had like another movie going on whenever
she needed to film her katana scenes or
vice-versa but either way now we have a
Wolverine actress I already did a big
video explaining katanas back story in
the comics so I'll link that in the
description but the idea is that the
show will use her in the Hong Kong
flashbacks and in the present hopefully
she'll teach Oliver how to use a sword
the interesting thing is that usually
when characters on the show go from the
past to the present it has something to
do with the big villain arc it's like
Black Canary in Slade in season 2 they
were all in the island together and then
they were all in present-day together so
this season Ra's al Ghul is the big bad
so if katana is gonna show up in the
past and in the present it's probably
going to have something to do with him
in the League of Assassins that also
makes me wonder if the League of
Assassins has something to do with
Amanda Waller's operation in Hong Kong
in those flashbacks they do a good job
of putting clues about the big villain
arc and the season premieres every year
so be sure to keep your eyes peeled for
things that connect katana Oliver Amanda
Waller and Ra's al Ghul in that first
episode and Fukushima is a great action
actress so you should get really excited
she's gonna be awesome on the show
speaking of crossover characters and
comebacks there's another Tommy
flashback scene this season for Hong
Kong the idea is that Tommy is there for
some unrelated reason and Oliver almost
runs into him that makes me wonder if
Malcolm Merlyn is gonna show up in the
flashbacks to the timelines get a little
fuzzy but yet to remember it this way
Malcolm Merlyn was in Starling while
Oliver was gone Malcolm Merlyn was in
the League of Assassins while Oliver was
still like really young way before he
ever got stranded on the island so if
Merlyn said Hong Kong he will have
already left the League of Assassins I'm
actually a little frustrated I haven't
seen John Barrowman in any of the
promos yet hopefully they're gonna pry
post one pretty soon hopefully he'll be
in that one supposedly they're going to
be posting an official version of the
olicity kiss promo that leaked online so
hopefully you guys are get a chance to
see that in nice high quality aside from
Merlin though the only other character
I'm expecting to see in any of these new
promos between now and the premiere are
Ray Palmer like brain and Rao's
character the probably try to explain
him just a little bit better while we
wait for that super high quality promo
to post I'm gonna be working on a new
Marvel video for Avengers age of Ultron
there's been some Captain Marvel talk
they've been talking about taking her
out of the movie just the way they
introduced her so you can click here to
get that I'll post that tonight a lot of
the annotation whenever I post and you
can click here to get my katana
backstory video to learn about her from
the comics thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you